[موسيقى] الغضب يغلي في هذا البلد الذي تكتنفه أزمات متعددة واقتصاد منهار يتصاعد من نقص في الغذاء والوقود مع استمرار الغليان في الغليان بسبب انفجار مرفأ بيروت في أغسطس الماضي حمل أقارب القتلى في ذلك الانفجار صوراً للضحايا وتوابيت وهمية إلى منزل وزير الداخلية اللبناني المؤقت ، سرعان ما تحولت الاحتجاجات إلى هرج ومرج مساء الثلاثاء. العدالة في الوقت الذي أثبتت فيه تلك الوعد مثل العديد من الدول الأخرى أن لبنان فارغًا ، والذي كان يُعرف سابقًا باسم سويسرا الشرق الأوسط ، ينهار منذ ما يقرب من عامين ، حيث كان الاقتصاد في حالة سقوط حر ازداد سوءًا بسبب جائحة فيروس كورونا المستجد ، يلتقط المرسى كيسًا من الطعام. برنامج إذاعة محلية لمساعدة المحتاجين منذ عامين  كانت
قيمة آري أكثر من ثمانمائة دولار
الآن ، وهي الآن أقل من ثمانين
في محطة وقود في أعلى الشارع ،
يصطف الناس
لساعات ، ونحن ذاهبون إلى الجحيم ،
تحصل بيروت في أحسن الأحوال
على بضع ساعات فقط من الكهرباء في اليوم ،
وفقًا لتقارير الأمم المتحدة  أن ما يقرب من
80 في المائة من العائلات هنا
ليس لديها ما يكفي من الطعام لتأكله بينما
يصف البنك
الدولي الأزمة الاقتصادية في لبنان بأنها واحدة من أسوأ الأزمات التي
شهدها العالم في الـ 150
عامًا الماضية ، ولا يزال القاع غير
مرئي في أي مكان
قبل أيام رئيس الوزراء المؤقت
هنا
حذر من أن لبنان على بعد أيام من
انفجار اجتماعي
قد يكون على حق بن ويدمان سي إن إن
بيروت